ils se sont illustrés dans tous les
conflits du monde
leurs interventions furent souvent
déterminante
et les forces
entraînés aux limites de la résistance
humaine ces hommes sont prêts à donner
leur vie pour servir la cause qu'ils ont
choisi
mélange détonnant d'histoire et l'action
une fresque vivante sur mes unités de
combat les plus secrètes des grandes
puissances militaires
films d'archivés documents contemporains
témoignages sur le vif mission tradition
combat
une collection unique sur les troupes
des villes prestigieuses au monde
élite force
forces d'élite
pendant 160 ans ils ont combattu pour la
france dans des batailles que bien
souvent la france préférerait oublier
au delà de leur réputation de canaille 0
hic ce sont des mercenaires qui
pratiquent l'honneur sans frontières
ils forment la légion étrangère peu de
militaires peuvent se glorifier de
combats qu'ils n'ont pas gagné mais pour
la légion sauvegarder l'honneur mais
plus important que de vaincre
elle respecte à cette tradition à
vientiane phu en 1954 à l'heure où la
france perdait définitivement l'ado
chine
après la défaite du japon en 1945
l'armée et l'administration coloniale
française avait tenté de reprendre le
contrôle qu'elle exerçait précédemment
sur cette région d'asie un effort
coûteux et stérile de huit années contre
une coalition de guérir aux communistes
et de nationalistes vietnamiens décidé à
chasser les étrangers de leur sol une
guerre qui ne laissait aucune place aux
grands sentiments une impitoyable guerre
à la mesure de la légion qui avait été
engagé trente mille de ses hommes
mais guého patria nostra la légion est
notre patrie c'est leur devise ils sont
loyaux envers leurs camarades et envers
leurs officiers pour lesquels ils
marchent ou meurs comme en indochine au
paroxysme de cette guerre games viennent
fou l'exemple même de ce qu'il ne faut
pas faire face 53 la france avait
déployé de manière insensée ses
meilleures forces dans cette cuvette
entourée de collines entièrement aux
mains de l'ennemi vietminh tout l'hiver
détournant l'attention du commandement
français par quelques escarmouches ses
adversaires s'installèrent solidement il
renforçaient leurs positions de dizaines
de milliers d'hommes et de centaines de
canaux
les français manquaient rapidement
d'effectifs et d'équipements
alors que le combat ne s'essaie de
s'intensifier
m
la bataille décisive pour dieng floue
entre dans son deuxième mois
des renforts sont aéroportée la garnison
les paras sont engagés dans une bataille
incertaine
un contingent touche le sol les met
aussitôt en action ses mitrailleuses et
ses mortiers
l'opération soulage les défenseurs dont
la résistance est dès à présent entrer
dans l'histoire
les français exploite au maximum leur
supériorité aérienne avant que la
mousson ne cloue leurs avions au sol à 1
contre 4
il repousse les attaques de part et
d'autre on se bat avec acharnement tous
volontaires les hommes de la légion qui
ont sauté sur des miennes pouces avec
une évacuation était impossible et que
par tradition
il n'était pas question pour eux de se
rendre
ils se sont effectivement battu jusqu'à
la dernière cartouche
le 8 mai 1954 lorsque la place tombe à
8000 d'entre eux avaient été tués
ce sacrifice et symbolique des missions
de la légion à la fois garnison
coloniale et corps expéditionnaire et
dont les recrues ont l'avantagé d'être
anonyme beaucoup plus facile à sacrifier
dans une aventure militaire que des
conscrits de nationalité française
aucune unité combattante n'a suscité
autant de respect oh que non plus n'a
engendré autant de mystères de
controverse et d'histoire romanesque
en un siècle et demi la confrérie du
képi blanc a recruté plus de six cent
mille hommes de 100 nationalités
différentes et dont trente cinq mille
sont morts au combat
venus des quatre coins du monde uni par
la tradition comme par leurs
entraînements quotidiens
ils se considèrent comme des frères la
légion est leur vraie famille
la mystique de la légion n'a cessé
d'exciter l'imagination populaire
on ne compte plus les récits et les
films illustrant le courage du
légionnaire son audace son abbaye sens
aux ordres et son esprit le corps
cette réputation d'honneur et de
bravoure puiser pour une bonne part dans
quelques campagne héroïque menée dans
les déserts africains doit pourtant son
plus beau fleuron à une défaite subie
dans un lieu perdu il y à bien longtemps
et dont la légion pourtant c'est fait un
titre de gloire
chaque année le 30 avril
les légionnaires commémore cameron
il n'ya pas d'héritage dont ils soient
plus fier
en 1861 alors que la guerre de sécession
déchire à l'amérique du nord
napoléon iii décida de se tailler un
fief dans le nouveau monde mais souvent
france est envahie le mexique pour
placer à sa tête et sous son contrôle
maximilien d'autriche décrété empereur
la légion fut envoyée sur place
elle comptait bien trouver quelques
occasions de s'illustrer dans cette
aventure exotique l'expédition ne
manquera effectivement pas d'épisode
glorieux mais surtout sanglant
les mexicains ne voulait évidemment pas
de cette recolonisation ils résistèrent
le corps expéditionnaire français
passent à de 3000 à 40 mille hommes la
guerre s'enlise à mais la légion allait
se trouver une âme dans cette campagne
du mexique en avril 1863 une compagnie
de 65 légionnaires et surprise par deux
mille soldats mexicains
elle se retranche dans une ferme du
petit village de cameron
durant toute une journée sous un soleil
de plomb les défenseurs repousse tous
les assauts le soir six survivants à
court de munitions font une sortie à la
baïonnette avant de succomber sous le
nombre l'unité été commandée par le
capitaine danjou dont l'âme artificielle
retrouvé sur le lieu de la bataille
demeure l'une des reliques les plus
précieuses de la légion le symbole d'une
solidarité fraternelle dans le combats
futiles désespéré
l'acte de naissance de la légion est
daté du 9 mars 1831 à la suite des
émeutes qui avaient amené l'année
précédente charles 10 à abdiquer
louis-philippe était monté sur le trône
il souhaitait se rallier les vétérans
étrangers des guerres napoléoniennes
ce n'étaient pas des enfants de choeur
il se devait de ceux qui quinze ans plus
tôt avait presque conquis l'europe
depuis lors ils vivaient médiocrement
d'une demi soldes obsédé la fois par les
récents troubles révolutionnaires et par
les problèmes que lui posait
l'expédition d'algérie le nouveau
monarque décida de transformer en avant
poste colonial ses troupes excédentaire
et remuante son ministre de la guerre
allait résumer cette politique en
quelques mots ils versent leur sang et
pioche le sable à la conquête de
l'afrique du nord
en 1832 ses soldats se dire interdire de
servir en france seuls des recrues
étrangères combattre et outre mer sous
commandement français pour la plus
grande gloire de l' empire et sans que
des veuves soient obligés de pleurer
leurs morts
les légionnaires n'avait déjà ni passé
ni futur
aujourd'hui la tradition demeure
on reçoit des gens qui quand ils
arrivent eux mêmes ne savent pas ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire et on
s'aperçoit après qu'ils sont capables de
faire beaucoup et même le découvre et je
crois que c'est ça la légion étrangère
c'est le fait de faire découvrir de
découvrir nous permet de faire découvrir
des gens qu'ils sont capables de se
surpasser
pour beaucoup le légionnaire ne peut
être qu'un homme qui cherche à échapper
un passé douteux
ce n'est en tout cas plus vrai
aujourd'hui la légion ne recrute pas
sans poser de questions elle ferme les
yeux sur les délits mineurs
mais elle écarte les casier judiciaire
chargé les recrues sont généralement des
hommes jeunes soucieux d' aventure de
discipline et de servir dans une arme
d'élite mais comme ils sont en majorité
étrangers il reflète logiquement tous
les bouleversements qui agitent le monde
on s'engage dans la légion ils sont à la
recherche d'un père soit que l'on prend
pas familles lésées rejeté soit que leur
pays où on n'ait pas été à même de
satisfaire leurs espérances au vétéran
des guerres du 19e siècle ont succédé
dans les années 20 des russes blancs
rescapés de la révolution bolchévique
puis dans les années 30 des réfugiés
espagnols
d'anciens nazis ont rejoint la légion
après de la deuxième guerre
plus récemment les restrictions
militaire que s'est imposée la grande
bretagne après la guerre des malouines
ont suscité un afflux de volontaires
britannique et depuis la chute du mur de
berlin
40% des recrues sont originaires
d'europe de l'est dans toute
organisation militaire l'aspect
extérieur constitue la première étape du
conditionnement
ici il ne s'agit pas seulement que tout
se ressemble
mais que chacun s'identifie physiquement
au régiment la sélection dure deux
semaines
elle vise à déterminer si les candidats
ont la capacité d'endurer la discipline
et les rigueurs de la légion leur
loyauté doit être absolue la plupart
choisissent de rompre tout lien avec
leur passé je couperai les ponts avec ma
famille jusqu'au terme de mon contrat
seule la légion permet à ceux qui la
rejoignent de taire leur nationalité ou
de s'engager sous un nom d'emprunt
il ne s'agit pas seulement de permettre
aux volontaires de repartir à zéro mais
de subordonner la personnalité de
l'individu à une identité collective
purement légionnaires
les hommes sélectionnés reçoivent
aussitôt le képi blanc mais ils devront
encore se contenter de l'admirer ils ne
pourront le porter qu'après seize
semaines d'entraînement éreintant dans
le sud de la france
pour les candidats c'est un événement
qui va bouleverser leur vie c'est
cosmopolite ont désormais une nouvelle
citoyenneté
ils sont les gérer le contrat
d'enrôlement vous lie à votre nouvelle
famille pour cinq ans il concrétise
solennellement votre nouveau départ vous
l'avez choisi et il m'a votre volonté de
servir la légion étrangère avec honneur
et fidélité
seule la légion vous offre cette chance
un entraînement militaire efficace ne
peut être éprouvant
les vétérans affirme un entraînement
facile guère difficile à un entraînement
difficile guère facile à castelnaudary
dans les pyrénées et les recrues sont
rapidement confrontés à leur nouveau
rythme de vie elles sont testés
mentalement et physiquement
cela ne se fait pas toujours sans mal
par rapport au passé certains abus sont
évités mais l'entraînement reste très
dur à la mesure de ce que l'on exigerait
des hommes s'il était engagé au combat
la plupart de ceux qui ne le supportent
pas sont déclarés inaptes d'autres
déserte
beaucoup d'exercices sont conçus pour
encourager la solidarité la légion
réfrène l'individualisme au bénéfice de
l'esprit l'équipe en la matière tout
écart est sévèrement corrigé changé
winston
nous voulons des unités solidement soudé
l'entraînement l'accent est mis sur le
travail collectif
nous ne recherchons pas les rendre au
les meilleurs tireurs d'élite où les
officiers les plus brillants les
personnalités d'exception ne nous
intéresse pas ce que nous voulons c'est
un esprit de corps une conduite
exemplaire au niveau de la section de la
compagnie du régiment
ce qui fait la force de la légion ces
c'est une idée qu'il avait virtuellement
est destructible
il n'est pas inhabituel d'entendre
parler 10 langues différentes dans un
groupe de recrues mais sur le champ de
bataille
il est essentiel que les ordres soient
suivies instantanément c'est une
question de vie ou de mort
il est donc indispensable qu'à l'issue
de leur entraînement les candidats
puissent maîtriser le français
production généralement après une
période de flottement ils y parviennent
la région a aussi ses traditions tout un
répertoire de chants légionnaires se
transmet de génération en génération
ces marches imprégné souvent d'une forte
influence germanique ponctuent les
rituels de la vie quotidienne elle
célèbre la loyauté l'abnégation la
camaraderie tout ce qui aide à affronter
la mort
alors nous avons une matière humaine
vous avez pu le constater qu'ils s'en
remet totalement la légion étrangère
et là dessus nous en tant que cadre on a
un rôle c'est de ne pas de répondre à
leurs attentes
ce qui nous maintient toujours en éveil
vis-à-vis d'eux est donc vis-à-vis de la
légion étrangère en faire les meilleurs
parce qu'ils sont très exigeants
engagé volontaire de la section de
l'adjudant ménard
les meilleurs ont mérité maintenant de
porter les attributs qui les identifie
comme légionnaires à part entière leur
insigne leur sont remis au cours de la
célèbre cérémonie du képi blanc qui se
déroule traditionnellement au coucher du
soleil c'est le moment d'émotion celui
où les volontaires sont amenés à se
rappeler que les sources de leur
vocation mélange le sang et la gloire
mon provenant de celles hors école
ensemble ils récitent leur code
d'honneur qui applique discipline
loyauté courage il jure de considérer
leur mission comme sacrés de les
exécuter à la lettre
jusqu'au sacrifice de leur vie la
première tâche confiée à la légion en
1832 fut de pacifier l'algérie au nom de
l'impérialisme français pour repousser
ces étrangers infidèle et mépriser les
chefs de tribus avaient proclamé une
dyade une guerre sainte
les légionnaires subir leur baptême du
feu dans des luttes sauvage et
meurtrière sous un soleil de plomb sur
une terre d'embuscades et contre des
ennemis fanatisés
l'armée française d'algérie attendit
longtemps sa première vraie victoire
elle a remporté à le 24 juin 1857
lorsque dans une charge épique à la
baïonnette
les légionnaires enlevèrent l'oasis
fortifiée de zaâtcha assurant
provisoirement le contrôle français sur
l'afrique du nord
entre temps la france avait changé de
régime
napoléon iii succès des alouettes
philippe lempire c'est la paix
proclamait le nouveau souverain pas de
paix pour la légion
en 1854 éclate à la guerre de crimée les
russes méditait de s'emparer de
constantinople pour accéder à la
méditerranée
les légionnaires formèrent l'avant-garde
de la sau décisif qui leva le siège de
sébastopol et ruina les espoirs du tarn
le temps était aux aventures coloniales
la légion avait besoin d'une base
permanente ont établi à sidi bel abbès
près d'oran tout en étant proche de la
france l'algérie on était suffisamment
éloigné pour que ces turbulents
mercenaires ne pose aucun problème à
l'état major
en même temps qu'elle s'installait à
sidi bel abbès où elle restera plus d'un
siècle la légion faisait peau neuve en
adoptant une nouvelle tenue
pantalon et képi blanc tunique bleue au
19e siècle les conscrits formaient
l'essentiel des armées nationales la
légion fit exception aguerris
disciplinée elle développa des unités
spécialisées des troupes montées des
grenadiers des bataillons d'intervention
riche de l'expérience que lui apportait
ses recrues étrangères
elle devint un outil essentiel de
l'expansion politique et économique de
la france
durant la campagne de madagascar à la
fin du siècle la fièvre terrassa plus
d'hommes que l'adversaire un médecin
militaire note
un soldat français entre à l'hôpital
pour être renvoyé chez lui un tirailleur
africain pour y être soignés a
légionnaires pour y mourir
à l'époque le jugement que portaient les
français sur leurs troupes mercenaires
étaient très mitigé et il le restera
jusqu'à la grande guerre
pour la première fois la légion
étrangère étaient autorisés à combattre
sur le sol français
céron ce confrère d'un nouvel afflux
d'étrangers acquis à la cause des alliés
tous les continents y était représenté
avec en vedette une poignée d'aviateur
américain
anticipant quelque sorte l'entrée en
guerre de leur pays ils formèrent
l'escadrille la fayette
depuis 1915 toutes les unités
d'infanterie de la légion été regroupés
en un seul régiment de marche
trois ans plus tard ce régiment était le
plus décoré de france
le poète et légionnaires américain alan
seghers écrivait quelques heures avant
d'être tuée avec 862 ses camarades à la
bataille de belloy en santerre j'ai un
rendez vous avec la mort à minuit dans
quelques villes en flammes quand
reviendra le printemps et je vous en
donne ma parole je serai fidèle au
rendez vous
après la guerre est affecté à sidi bel
abbès la légion repris ses missions
coloniale
en 1925 des tribus montagnardes conduite
par un les généralement déserteurs
entrèrent en rébellion
il fallu plus d'un an pour les réduire
la même année la légion fut engagée en
syrie contre les druzes farouchement
opposé à la décision prise par la
société d'une nation de confier à la
france
le mandat de gérer cette région durant
la deuxième guerre mondiale les
l'hygiène et en échappée repas à la
tourmente leur régiment seront divisés
entre eux
fidélité à vichy et devoir de résistance
cependant après s'être illustrée déjà
aux premiers jours du conflit en norvège
ils se retrouveront aux premières loges
en afrique leur terrain de prédilection
contre l'afrikakorps de rommel
pendant dix jours à bir-hakeim leur
ténacité contribué pour beaucoup à
permettre à la viiie armée britannique
de se regrouper et de couper au renard
du désert la route de l'egypte une fois
la france libérée la légion fille table
rase de ses conflits internes préoccuper
tout entière de participer à l'assaut
final contre les nazis
la victoire sur l'allemagne
nos frites aux légionnaires qu'un bref
répit quelques mois plus tard fortement
renforcée au passage d'anciens soldats
de la wehrmacht
ils étaient engagés dans un nouveau
conflit en indochine
les pertes effrayante que subit la
légion à dien bien phu ne faisait que
préludé à d'autres massacres à une autre
salle guerre fin 1954 éclatait
l'insurrection algérienne
les légionnaires vous participez dans ce
pays qui était un peu leur à l'une des
guerres les plus impitoyables de l'ère
moderne une lutte à mort contre le fln
et les autres mouvements
indépendantistes
pour les français les insurgés étaient
des terroristes il l'aiderait terre donc
comme des criminels la détermination de
leurs adversaires finira pourtant par
les décourager la volonté du président
de gaulle de négocier l'indépendance de
l'algérie
apparu à certains militaires comme une
trahison en avril 1961 3000 soldats dont
beaucoup appartenaient au 1er régiment
étranger de parachutistes sous terre un
putsch tendant à placer le pays sous
contrôle militaire
la mutinerie fit long feu
une grande majorité des forces armées
refusable participer mais la légion elle
s'était gravement compromise le 1er rep
fut démantelée et plusieurs de ses chefs
emprisonnés
un an plus tard l'algérie accédait à
l'indépendance après ceux déjà subi en
indochine ces nouveaux déboires
entraînèrent une réduction des effectifs
de la légion dont le quartier général de
sidi bel abbès fut par ailleurs rapatrié
à aubagne près de marseille
la légion et d'une famille qui s'assume
ces vétérans sont accueillis au foyer de
puyloubier construit alors attention
grâce à des donations de leurs camarades
en service
le domaine proche d'aix en provence est
une terre de vignobles ce vénérable
caviste a derrière lui une carrière de
légionnaires de plus de 30 ans sassou de
vin rouge
nous faisons pas ce mot de vin rouge
nous faisons aussi de vin blanc
tu vas un roseau de bandes banc que d'un
mousseux et de l'eau du bain
nous sommes ici dans la salle des
campagnes du musée la légion étrangère à
aubagne
aujourd'hui humile 500 hommes servent
dans la légion avec un renouvellement
annuel de 15 cents leurs officiers sont
en grande majorité français mais rien
n'interdit qu'un étranger accède à un
poste de commandement
l'effectif est répartie en dix unités
spécialisées dans des tâches qui vont de
la sécurité à l'ingénierie mais tout
légionnaire doit être apte à combattre
et reste soumis dans ce but à un
entraînement permanent
les exercices sont éprouvants conçu pour
reproduire dans toute la mesure du
possible les exigences réelles de la
guerre moderne
je
ces épreuves sont réputés fournir la
confiance en soi qui fait les
combattants efficace l'instruction est
assurée par les sergents et les caporaux
très exigeants ils sont chargés de
maintenir dans l'unité son haut niveau
de performance et son grand esprit de
solidarité les légionnaires apprennent à
pratiquer toutes les formes de combat et
même à tuer à mains nues terminé larmes
réglementaire et le famas un fusil
d'assaut de calibre 5 56 qui se charge
par le bas un bis pied amovible lui
assure une ligne de tir très précise
mais la légion forces d'élite dispose
d'un arsenal autrement plus
impressionnant des armes robuste d'un
maniement aisé et d'une grande puissance
de feu
ainsi ce fusil de calibre 7,62 à haute
précision jusqu'à une distance de 600 m
la plus récente unité de la légion a été
créée en 1984
c'est le 6e régiment étranger du génie
son rôle est d'accompagner la fonderie
dans les zones d'opération pourrait
construire de quoi les protéger et
assurer leur progression
ces hommes sont aussi expert en
explosifs
ces sapeurs sont formés à la pose des
mines est alors détection aucune
technologie ne peut remplacer la
neutralisation manuel de ces engins
redoutable
allez y
d'autres spécialistes sont entraînés au
repérage des mines sous marines et les
assauts enfile ses sapeurs joue aussi un
rôle politique comme constructeur dans
des missions militaires
outre mer
la tradition du guerrier bâtisseurs est
perpétuée au sein de la plus ancienne
unité
le 1er régiment dont l'unité de sapeurs
défilent en tête lors de la
commémoration de cameron escortant la
main de bois du capitaine danjou le
tablier de cuir qu'il porte sur leur
uniforme symbolise la vocation de
bâtisseurs des légionnaires
beaucoup à l'eau
les régiment étranger d'infanterie
servent aux quatre coins du monde le
troisième héros y est spécialement
formés au combat dans la jungle
il y écoles les autres unités de la
légion et occasionnellement des troupes
d'élite venant de divers pays
on n'a pas le riz c'est la longue
attente à apprivoiser un autre groupe
d'infanterie serre dans la corne de
l'afrique est une région dur à vivre
même pour aller génère son déploiement
est considéré comme indispensable à la
sauvegarde des intérêts français au
moyen-orient
un régiment de cavalerie le 1er rec
constituent le noyau de la force
d'intervention rapide de la france c'est
une unité polyvalente très mobiles
équipés de tanks léger et de transports
de troupes blindés
le premier rec tire sa puissance de feu
d'un armement ultramoderne et notamment
de missiles antichars vab hot
c'est à mx dispersé servi par un
équipage de quatre hommes sont équipés
d'un canon de 105 mm leur vitesse de
pointe dépasse 90 km heure ils sont
considérés comme la rolls royce du
désert
enfin le 2e rep régiment de
parachutistes passe auprès des
légionnaires eux-mêmes pour le nec plus
ultra
une unité dont les recrues sont triés
sur le volet j'ai servi auparavant au
troisième ris en amérique du sud et au
1er rec
mais comme tous mes camarades je rêvais
hêtre parachutistes et c'est le seul
régiment de la légion qui soit
aéroportée nous sommes les meilleurs
l'élite de la légion
les paras s'entraîne au saut très
régulièrement sur des avions transal au
départ de leur base en corse à une unité
spéciale de commande ou baptisé craps
est destiné à opérer derrière les lignes
ennemies en éclaireur le craps et
équipés d'armes d'assaut sophistiquée
avec viseur de nuit et silencieux et
d'un matériel ultramoderne de
positionnement sur satellite et de
démolition contrôlée par radio
leur régiment parachutiste vit en état
d'alerté permanent
non
mais
où
je
non
aujourd'hui en cas de crise
nous sommes les pompiers de l'armée
française pas équipés de blindés ni
équipe est forcément très lourdement en
véhicules contre la guerre chimique en
la france ambitionne de renforcer
économiquement et militairement son
influence internationale en cas de
conflit la légion constitue un de ses
atouts majeurs
elle a été engagée dans cet esprit à
trois reprises au tchad
elle a protégé le régime en place d'une
série de coup d'état inspiré par la
libye
78 à kolwezi au zaïre où une invasion
d'aix qu'attendait menaçaient la vie des
résidents européens
le colonel gosseries a sauté avec la
première vague dans un assaut devenir
légendaire je sautais en première vague
derrière le colonel erulin il s'agissait
bien d'une opération coup de poing
puisque le régiment a sauté le 19 mai je
suis rentré à quelle vie le 6 juin
opération don de va-et-vient très rapide
très brutale alors actions humanitaires
dont je rappelle que nous avons sauvé
2000 européen de massacre elle a
malheureusement eu 150 qu'on a retrouvés
dans des charniers totalement massacré
et à l'époque qu'on a permis au zaïre de
récupérer le chabat qui sa province la
plus riche
en 1982 à beyrouth la légion à
participer à la force internationale qui
a protégé le retrait des hommes de l'ol
paie
le gouvernement français utilisent la
légion comme un élément de dissuasion
dont la seule présence suffit parfois à
calmer des situations explosives
ce fut le cas au rwanda où sont arrivés
à 8 et l'extension de la guerre civile
ces opérations réclame un entraînement
spécifique
ici au sénégal le 2e rep participaient à
des manoeuvres conjointes qui témoigne
de l'engagement continu de la france
dans son ancien empire
au cours de l'exercice des parachutistes
sont lâchés sur place après un vol de
neuf heures effectuées au départ de
toulouse entraîné par des vents violents
ils ont atterri à deux kilomètres de
leur zone de largage et s'active à
récupérer leurs équipements avant le
coucher du soleil
les hommes ont sauté avec un paquetage
de près de 30 kg des vivres pour trois
jours des munitions un équipement de
survie une trousse médicale
tout ce qu'ils seraient amenés à
transporter s'il monte est réellement au
combat
la légion ne constitue qu'un des
éléments de la force d'intervention
française appelée à démontrer ici en
coopération avec des unités sénégalaise
sa capacité à contrôler rapidement un
terrain qui ne lui est pas familier
des hélicoptères assurent la protection
aérienne de l'opération tandis que sur
la plage des hommes grenouilles
garantissent les voies d'accès un
débarquement la marine française
transporte sur les plages des véhicules
blindés et des unités du génie
une stratégie efficace est aujourd'hui
tributaire de cette mobilité et de cette
rapidité d'intervention
bush
les habitants de la région observent les
légionnaires qui se taille un chemin à
travers la brousse
ils savent que l'armée française
constitue le plus sûr allié de leur
gouvernement
cette compagnie a reçu pour mission
d'effectuer une reconnaissance dans une
bourgade qui est censé abriter des
éléments hostiles
elle a pour objectif de les neutraliser
et d'assurer le contrôle de la région et
des voies ferroviaires qui convergent
les légionnaires à placer aux
avant-postes jouent leur rôle avec
conviction ce qui ne les empêche pas
d'organiser de manière tout aussi
réaliste leurs quelques moments de
détente
faux
on s'efforce ici de reproduire les
conditions d'un affrontement réel la
manoeuvre laisse une part à
l'improvisation
on est requis d'y faire preuve d'astuce
et d'initiative
là où les défenseurs attendait un lâcher
de parachutistes par avion on leur
réserve la surprise d'un assaut par
hélicoptère
une attaque surprise de ce genre est de
celles auxquelles les légionnaires sont
entraînés à faire face
ils doivent aussi être capable de
combattre la guérilla caractéristiques
des opérations dans le tiers-monde
l'ennemi se fondant dans la nature pour
éviter d'affronter une troupe compact
est organisée
les manoeuvres sont terminés après la
traditionnelle revue des troupes et une
dernière inspection
les légionnaires pourront pendant
quelques heures se détendre et sacrifié
au tourisme
non sans avoir été mis en garde contre
les méfaits de la drogue de l'amour
tarifé et des marchands de souvenirs
la coopération militaire vue pour
quelques heures sous l'angle des
relations publiques
ces exercices outre-mer font partie de
l'information générale des légionnaires
de leur préparation à toute forme de
guerre
et lorsque la guerre se déclenche comme
ce fut le cas dans le golfe
il permet à la légion de renouer
instantanément avec ses traditions
n'avait rien d'exceptionnel l'armée
française en général et la légion en
particulier sont habitués à combattre
dans le désert
les légionnaires se sont parfaitement
intégrés à l'ensemble du dispositif
militaire français déployés dans le
golfe et des éléments de toutes leurs
unités avaient été envoyés sur place le
1er régiment étranger de cavalerie le 6e
régiment étranger du génie le 2e
régiment étranger d'infanterie et les
commandos du 2e régiment étranger
parachutiste la légion était en première
ligne sur la frontière entre l'arabie
saoudite et l'irak forme en tenaille sur
l'ale des forces alliées elle était
chargée de forcer les fortifications
irak n est de prendre la ville et
l'aéroport de à salman
une attaque rapide et violente
le succès est total
pris à revers les irakiens baisse les
armes
les légionnaires n'ont pas subi la
moindre perte
ces opérations ont démontré l'aptitude
de la légion à remplir son rôle dans une
bataille de grande envergure et la
fiabilité du matériel dont on l'adopté
elle réalise l'équation parfaite entre
une technologie de pointe et les valeurs
traditionnelles du combattant
elle a impressionné ses alliés et le
général schwarzkopf s'est montré très
flatté d'être nommé caporal d'honneur
cette guerre marquera peut être l'avenir
de la légion sans doute jouer de plus en
plus à combattre dans des forces
internationales de maintien de la paix
sa polyvalence et son professionnalisme
sont parfaitement adaptés à ce genre de
mission
son engagement dans le golfe a permis à
la légion de tester son expérience dans
une vaste opération combinée
elle y avait remis son moral et son
esprit de corps
la france veut apporter à ces nouvelles
alliances la caution d'une arme est apte
à la fois à remplir des missions
humanitaires et à tenir son rang au
combat
les événements qui ont bouleversé
récemment le coeur de l'europe ont amené
les 12 pays de la communauté à s'engager
militairement de l'adriatique au
kurdistan
la nécessité s'impose de créer une
réelle cohésion entre leurs armées
respectives
par nature la légion pourrait être à
l'avant garde de cette mutation
tout comme ses alliés la france est
confrontée à des difficultés économiques
qui l'amèneront sans doute à réduire ses
effectifs militaires mais la légion
n'est pas une unité comme les autres
besoin d'unité capables d'intervenir à
la fois dans des engagements armés pour
rétablir la paix ou pour pour venir en
aide à des pays
agresser ou
où l'objet de convoitise de pays voisins
la légion étrangère constitue un exemple
unique d'autres armes et aligne des
troupes parfaitement équipés entraînés
et motivés
ce qui caractérise le légionnaire c'est
leur dévouement
non pas à leur pays mais à leur unité
depuis plus de 160 ans la légion
rassemble des hommes de nationalité de
race et de religion différente mais des
hommes solidaires dans leur credo d'un
autre âge
marche ou crève
le haut
oh